it's not about black and white it's
about the continuous culture
appropriation and falsification of
history that has been done by what the
so-called afrocentris movement the
Afrocentric movement started the last
century as a way in a good intention to
teach African-American about their Rich
history of West Africa the great Empire
of Benin of Ghana over sungali the great
Empire of Mali but the thing is that's
why you find people like Kevin Hart Who
subscribes to these theories who claim
that his ancestors play uh build the
pyramids I'm sorry your ancestors had
their own wonderful civilization in West
Africa they are culture appropriating my
culture calling the people of Egypt of
today despite their skin tone that will
they call us as Invaders they we call
them as Intruders and and they are being
erased by from our own history